abdella Ali Mamoun est avec nous merci
merci d'être là on a on a on va prendre
les dernières questions alors Monsieur
Lima moi je suis très contente de vous
écouter ce ce soir parce
qu'effectivement ce matin quand je vous
ai entendu chezapuline de Malerbe
j'étais un peu effrayée et et et je
voilà et là je suis extrêmement rassurée
je trouve que ce que vous dites est
clair net précis euh sans ambiguïé et je
pense que c'est important de vous
entendre parler parce que moi souvent
ici je parle avec mon ami mundir et Gill
qui sont tous les deux de confession
musulmanes et on on on se dispute
souvent justement par rapport à la
parole des imams aujourd'hui en France
et moi je parle souvent de l'imam
chalgoui et là à chaque fois on me dit
non mais lui ça compte pas lui c'est un
mauvais imam limite lui il est Islam non
non eux deux ah non j'ai pas dit que
c'est un mauvais bah non vous dites que
non non non non non j'ai dit qu'il avait
du mal à conjuguer le verbe être et
avoir c'est pas c'est vous a dit qu'
représentit pas les musulm tout cas qui
n représent et moi je voulais savoirés
alors pourquoi donc justement pourquoi
il y a pourquoi il y a il y a une telle
comment dire haine envers cet imam
chalgoumi pourquoi c'est donc c'est un
mauvais imam pourquoi à chaque fois il
pourquoi il vit sous protection
policière alors que normalement c'est
une religion de paix pourquoi c'est à ce
point-là compliqué quand on quand on est
par exle dans la marche contre
l'antisémitisme quand on est un musulman
et qu'on et qu'on est caché parce qu'on
a honte de dire qu'on est dans cette
mche contre l'antisémitisme quels que
soient les propos que pourrait tenir
chalgoumi qui soit français ou euh on va
dire dehumour ou je sais quoi mais non
c'est pas de l'humour c'est la réalité
c'est un un homme qui ne sait pas parler
français et qui malheureusement a été
mis en avant euh et qui provoque une
certaine frustration dans la composante
musulman à qui on oblige excusez-moi à
qui on oblige euh d'être représenté par
un un par une personne qui même un
enfant de 3 ans parlerit parle mieux
français que lui c'est la réalité ça
c'est un premier point sur la forme
maintenant sur le fond maintenant sur le
fond un imam c'est un homme de paix moi
je suis un homme de paix j'appelle à la
paix je suis pas dans le camp d'Israël
ni dans le camp palestinien je suis pour
la paix je dois être un acteur un agent
qui doit promouvoir la réconciliation
hier encore hier monsieur shalgoui
disait que Israël doit gagner la guerre
et nous que je suis du côté d'Israël et
j'espère qu'elle va euh gagner la guerre
je dis ah donc ça veut dire qu'il est
dans le camp de la guerre je suis désolé
un imam ne doit pas parler comme ça ni
même un rabin ni même un curé les les
hommes de foi doivent être des hommes
qui doit qui doit être des hommes pour
promouvoir la paix et le C la guerre
contre le Hamas oui oui il parlait
contre bah la guerre il parle de la
guerre on peut le comprendre non la
guerre contre le Hamas on est tous à
vouloir la guerre contre le Hamas on
veut tous l'extermination du Hamas oui
bien sûr mais est-ce qu'on le veut au
détriment des populations palestiniennes
ah ça je sais pas ça vous bah oui mais
le problème c'est ça il y a il y a 11000
morts il y a des milliers de morts en
tout cas en tout cas des milliers de
morts ça c'est sûr on pourrait pas on
pourrait pas me faire dire autre chose
moi je vois des vidéos qui sont atroces
sur Internet sont aussi aussi atroces de
ce qui s'est passé voir même en nombre
puisque on parle de nombreendez le
nombre est beaucoup plus importantcun
journaliste indépendant à Gaza vous
devez le savoir je dis il y a aucun
journaliste indépendant à pourquoi on n
pas est-ce que vous croyez que les
gazaou mais c'est ça qui est hor est-ce
que vous croyez que les Gaza
sontazexqu pere000 mors à gaz c'est
peut-être une fausse information on va
se faire défoncer on pas le droit de
laisser parler fake news je suis désolé
rien ne dit qu'il a 11000 morts rien ne
dit d'ailleurs de la même
façonyz sa rien vou VO vidé
sont on vous montre les vidéos prouver a
des milliers de Mor est-ce que vous
voyez pas est-ce que vous voyez pas
est-ce que vous voyez pas la banque de
Gaza qui a été complètement
détruite est-ce qu'on voit pas
aujourd'hui la bande de Gaza qui est
totalement détruite pratiquement est-ce
que oui ou non on le voit ça on le voit
forcément il y avait des habitants tout
à fait bon B alors forcément ils sont
morts parce que si si on voit comond
comondrs sont Mor il VI je ne connais
pas le chiffre
de je refuse de donner une fake news et
d'approuver
une je n' sais
rien
rez écoutez moi la solution c'est que
Israël donne la permission à des ONG de
rentrer à Gaza et de compter les morts
bien israël
refuse VO donc encore un problème qui
vient d'Israël et pas des palestin vou
parler qu'est-ce vous voulez dire non
moi je dis que il fait du bien cet
homme-là cet homme-là il fait du bien ce
soir parce que moi je voulais pastin non
mais pas ce matin ce matin ce qu'il a
dit ce matin là moi je suis comme vous
je reconnais pas quelqu'un qui a parlé
comme ça moi je l'ai pas vu j'étais au
boulot je reconnais pas quelqu'un qui
qui qui a dit ça ce matin ce qu'il a dit
ce soir chaque chroniqueur l'a été de sa
question toutous un par un vous avez
rentrer chez vous vous faites le replay
tous un par un vous lui avez posé une
question est-ce que vous condamnez il
vous répond oui à chaque fois la marche
il vous a répondu pourquoi il a pas été
tout tout tout tout tout il a tout mis
dedans il a tout coché dedans il a fait
plaisir à tout le monde et vous
continuez encore à lui dire non il y a
pas 11000 morts alors s'il y en a pas
11000 peut-être qu'il y en a 4000
peut-être qu'il y en a 3000 même s'il y
en a 200 innocents c'est trop on peut
aussi dire on peut écouter deux versions
les gars comment on va aller vers la
paix si on dit tout le temps non il
s'est passé que le 7 octobre le 7
octobre on le on le condamne c'est
dégueulasse ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre c'est des innocents c'est des
tirs au hasard pour moi c'est terroriste
je le condamne mais on peut pas dire que
ce qu'il dit là lui il l'a inventé de de
l'arrêt de bus
je l'ai repris sur le chiffre de parceon
sait
rien la V de gaz détr g les G attends
con pas
n gaz B gaz G sont levés attention il y
a une bombe on se barre non si la ville
elle est détruite tu peux pas dire fake
news
fake 24 he vous voulez mil
person c'est qu'il ont demandé ont
demandé que 24 24
a demandé au Hamas de déplacer la
population vers le sud vers le camp de
recna
pas estce que l'État d'Israël a
demandé au dirigants du Hamas de
déplacer la population vers le sud de la
bande
gaz il vont tous se déplacer dans avec
cil
par
on les caches d'armes et les cach
d'armes qui sont placés sous les
hôpitaux est-ce que ça c'est de
nature pare par ici sur ce plateau moi
j'ai été le premier à condamner le Hamas
de mouvement terroriste j'ai été le
premier bien évidemment j'en ai eu les
retours d'accord des deux parties je me
souviens sur ce plateau oui bien
évidemment mais là je parle de moi donc
le mais on a on était sur ce plateau les
gens disaient et je me
souviens il cond la mass il dis 8ou mai
et on était ferme il y avait pas de 8
mai on condamne point là ce qui se passe
est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
avec l'imam comme l' l'a souligné mon
confrère il a il a répondu à tout ENF il
peut pas faire mieux et vous dites oui
mais non il y a pas de
c'é
catastropique mot il y a un mot il y a
un mot en France madame de mer qui qui
me fait dire moi je dis pas elle me fait
dire oui bien sûr c'est elle qui me fait
dire des chosesors qui parle à ma
placesie remption monsieur monsieur
l'imam a eu rédemption il est en train
de vous
dire comment pardon tu vois c'est encore
les 8 mai de toi machin donc si vous
c'est pas le c'est toujours cette cette
espèce de chose qui va gêner tu sais il
peut pas être plus clair écoutez je vais
vous dire une chose écoutez même ce soir
excusez-moi même ce soir comme ce matin
comme cet après-midi surbfm TV je n'ai
jamais sollicité l'autorisation de
monsieur le recteur de la Mosquée de
Paris et je ne parle en aucun cas en son
nom je ne suis ni le porte-parole de la
Grande Mosquée de Paris ni même te
parole du recteur monsieur le recteur
est suffisamment majeur et vacciné
intelligent pour défendre lui-même le la
mosquée qu'il représente moi aussi
aujourd'hui j'ai effectivement une une
collaboration et un travail que
j'accomplis parce que je pense qu'il
faut une unité des musulmans pour
essayer de faire avancer les choses en
France pour promouvoir un islam qui
s'intègre parfaitement dans le paysage
français et dans lequel on soit en
harmonie avec les lois et les valeurs de
la République c'est ce que nous
travaillons au sein de la de la Mosquée
de Paris et depuis des des mois des mois
on travaille dans ce sens-l on travaille
même avec des juifs et des rabins
monsieur Moché Lévin en fait partie
monsieur corci tous les jours chaque
fois chaque occasion invité à la mosquée
de Paris et vice-versa donc les
relations sont conviviales et
fraternelles et cordiales depuis très
longtemps avec la composante je n'ai pas
de leçons à recevoir
sur le fait que
aujourd'hui je je suis de tout cœur avec
la population et la composante juive de
France qui a été Vic victime
d'antisémitisme depuis le 7 octobre d'un
nombre choquant que que ce matin j'ai
été moi-même estomaqué je dis c'est pour
cela alors que pour nous on était
persuadé que non la communauté musulmane
depuis le début de de de la guerre a eu
une attitude digne et cetera nous
pensions qu'ilexistait pas d'acte
antisémite musulman et là c'est pour
cela qu'on me dit si si il y a eu 1240
donc permettez-moi d'avoir quand même la
le le le droit de de m'interroger sur à
la fois qui à l'origine de l'origine de
ces actes est-ce que ce sont des actes
néonazis est-ce que ce sont des actes
musulmans j'ai demandé des détails
jamais j'ai prononcé preuve ou doute
j'ai dit j'ai demandé des détails pour
justement travailler justement le
constatil G pas entendu l'z
entendu monsur d'avoir ét avec nous soir
allez vous coucher là
maintenant vous vous avez fait combien
d'émissions aujourd'hui 12 hein vous
avez fait combien d'émissions euh trois
TR tris en plus trois plus bon des des
choses personnelles que j'ai dû faire en
dans la journée c'est important de faire
des ch ou effectivement et donc depuis
ce matin je me suis pas reposé mais il
fallait il fallait que je vienne sur
votre plateau et et merci en tout cas
m'avoir invité c'est la première fois je
suis content d'être là avec toi
aujourd'hui avec plaisir et ça a été
votre préférée quand même cette émission
ouis ouis elle est beaucoup plus
conviviale en plus il y a un public il y
a un public formidable
merci d'avoir été là alors on va passer
c'est moi qui vous applaudit messieurs
dames merci merci d'AV